one thing you mostly have to worry about
if you go to the beach in australia is
the jellyfish i was going to say the
second thing that [ __ ] terrifies me
we have a ton of those jellyfish not
toxic jellyfish though oh but the ones
that are like extremely painful oh yeah
yeah i mean because like we you're
probably thinking of box jellyfish right
yes okay yeah like i've never seen that
in the waters i've never heard of anyone
getting stung by that but like that's
the one that can kill you yeah and
whatever people have yeah where it
puts you in so much pain that you drown
because you have zero control over your
body yeah it basically paralyzes you
immediately if people like survived
uh people have survived yeah but a lot
but i mean like it's it's a very
uncommon way oh sorry it's a very rare
way for anyone to like i think only like
maybe like two or three people die a
year from it or something so it's like
it's very very rare considering the
amount of people who go into the ocean
in australia like it's you've got to be
really unlucky fish jellyfish just scare
me yeah but i mean like i've been stung
by the other kind of jellyfish that's
way more common is they're called blue
bottle jellyfish and they're not they're
not toxic or anything like they won't
kill you but it hurts a lot when you get
sunburned yeah my friend got stung by
when we were swimming in the in like
some shitty ocean yeah
okay and and the trick in australia is
if you have a mate who's been stung by a
blue bottle you you pee on pee on that i
i think this is one of those rumors
though isn't it
it's just right by jojo fans all right i
don't think it actually i think i think
the actual way to do it is like you
gotta like pour vinegar or something on
it but
i'm kind of having your mate piss on you
feels relieving yeah it's not it's some
kind of like alkaline thing
when you say it out loud it does feel
like a scene from jojo yeah
you've been stung by a stand the only
thing
36 degrees right there dog like that
that's warm as [ __ ] this is why this
isn't a problem in the uk everyone's
always got a hot furnace ready for the
tea they're very just like get the tea
thermos
this could make it worse actually oh
really depending on how i said well uh
sorry for peeing on your leg that one
time
well i remember we were swimming and a
bunch of a bunch of the jellyfish is
washed up yeah oh that's normal yeah
i've i've seen that in the uk as well
bunch of them washed up and this little
ten-year-old didn't know what they were
i was i think i was twelve dived into it
yeah just like picked one up and then
there's nothing
ah
well you can you can pick them up by the
head yeah i know he picked it up by the
way
yeah that's probably immediately started
crying and screaming and oh [ __ ]
there was loads of them i remember i got
really freaked out because i was like
what the [ __ ] is that yeah this is not
how they were in finding nemo that's
what i remember
i think there was any journey fishing
for me a weird
fish yeah that wasn't that jellyfish
what weird
fish freak me out so much more than like
animals do like what is fishing on
animals
no fish fish right animals are animals
jellyfish isn't an animal i know it's an
animal but you're [ __ ] like what
cough like what like what the [ __ ] is
going on with fish i mean it doesn't
have a brain injury jellyfish is just
god's spunk
that's just what they are like fights
back
i mean like that's the closest way i
think ocean sperm is the ocean sperm
cell
you look at you know that mr incredible
meme where he's like smiling and
gradually getting like more sound yeah
like you look at dogs you're like yes
and you get out of like horses you're
like yes yeah then you get something
like rats you're like okay yeah and then
you start getting these weird fish yeah
and you're like what though like the
deep sea fish yeah then you start
getting led to the real [ __ ] weird
fish the ones like all like no eyes and
just all teeth yeah yeah
like what the [ __ ] is happening down
there it's like something it's like
creatures it is like legit like
the fit like what's going on with fish
[ __ ] like that yeah
it's kind of
like what who who is an episode of
science who's in charge what is up with
this
of the evolution down there it's like
out of control you guys heard about the
immortal jellyfish no no
listening so there is there is a species
of jellyfish that scientists believe are
like immortal like they cannot they
cannot be
killed by like time by old age so right
obviously they can still be killed by
external forces
or whatever but that's brilliant but
it's believed by scientists that they
are
in a sense immortal and that scares the
[ __ ] out of me that's just because
nothing should be immortal nothing alive
should be immortal that's just the
survivor stand from past seasons yeah
they just have like nowhere yeah that is
literally just a stand right
i can't die apparently they reckon that
aging is uh like a process like cells
and stuff yeah it's on purpose yeah i'm
not bullshitting right actually that
there is something called the immortal
jellyfish yeah apparently it just
regresses into like a pollen before and
then it comes back again oh yeah so it's
literally just like a single cell like
organism kind of deal where it's like
it's just forever just like re-creating
itself basically yeah yeah so a car
accident just turned back into a baby
that's a benjamin button
that's pretty that's [ __ ] cool yeah
yeah but could you imagine though if
like humans were able to somehow like
study that [ __ ] enough right and be like
we're trying i think yeah yeah and you
know being like all right this might
actually be like the key to immortality
what's the point of being immortal if
you get to 60 and you're like you're
useless at 60 and you're like what are
you gonna do for another hundred years
well that's why they can regress in age
as well because they're just like
yeah
they're gonna get to like a point where
they're like [ __ ] i can't like i can't
do sports anymore time to go back like
let's just say we can like keep you
alive right till 200 but like after 50
you start like you know you start
degrading and then 70 you're kind of
useless yeah yeah well you're just gonna
say i'm not saying all people are
useless by the way but like like you
personally can't do what you want right
what is the point of you being like
another 130 years another 100 years like
what are you gonna do like just like
catch up with like the rest of game of
thrones yeah that's why like that's why
like i remember uh [ __ ] you know like
in armor episodes yeah you know when
they have all those like old celebrities
from centuries ago
yeah yeah yeah i remember one of my
friends was like oh man wouldn't it be
cool if we like humanity got to that
point in technology i'm like no what are
you what do you want that would be
horrible
you'd just be sitting on a shelf for the
rest of humanity like the rest of yeah
time rest of time rest of time just just
doing what how do you like
how do you uh how do you have fun yeah
you're just a head in a [ __ ] jaw i
guess i'll i don't know perfect beat
boxing or something like yeah that's
that's all you can do
as a head just like
that trick right with the cherry stem
where you can tie it out
just what else you're going to do
well it's perfecto jojo vero
[Music]
oh what are you doing i'm just watching
the 6 000th of rerun of pokemon yeah i
mean like i mean like i i guess it's
like a really philosophical question of
if you could be immortal would you want
to be immortal and i'm just like
i i wouldn't want to be a muscle maybe i
wouldn't want to die at like say 80 or
90 or whatever but like there's a point
where i would like my body to keep up
with what i want to do right okay well
then different question
how old if you could choose how old
would you want to be when you die
to me it depends on how functional i am
yeah right because like yeah i've i've
met 90 years old 90 year olds who are
like still in like [ __ ] tip-top shape
yeah yeah yeah um and i've also met you
know like 60 year olds who have trouble
doing things that i would want to do as
well 50s yeah yeah yeah yeah it depends
on how unlucky you get really yeah yeah
yeah you know some of my friends you
know that that some of their dads like
55 already getting like dementia and
stuff yeah [ __ ] yeah i would hate to get
that especially if like my kids are
young like i don't want them to feel
like yeah they got to help me out yeah i
think i think the coolest answer was uh
like my grandad
um
apparently like in his twenties he was
like from from his twenties he was like
i'm gonna die at age 80. just like
just no cap i'm gonna die at age 80.
yeah and for the longest time i was like
why why would you say that from a young
age and he's like because it gives me a
time limit to do all the things i want
to do before i die right and so it's
like self-motivating and and this is how
much of a chad my granddad was he died
exactly at age 80.
and he was literally he was he was
literally like i'm i'm good man i'm good
to go i'll ask how he dies oh he died
from lung cancer but
i was gonna say i'm like the this man
yeah he was literally like on his 80th
birthday he was like i can go now with
like no regrets
waiting for the clock to turn
it's like ready to pour we're gonna pull
the plug
but like i thought i thought that was so
[ __ ] cool right because like there's
that like very common philosophy of like
you know if you became immortal you
would do nothing because you'd have no
like rush you have to drive to you don't
have to drive to do the things you want
to do right because you can do it
whenever you want so yeah i mean that's
my reasoning for why i wouldn't want to
be a model also like i don't know i
don't want to see everyone around me die
that should be so funny i mean like if
you live in a society where everyone can
choose how you know when oh sorry okay
so if we were living in an immortal
society yeah yeah society
if we lived in the society
then i think we'd just like regress to
the [ __ ] stone age at that point
because like no one would want to do
anything yeah yeah yeah i mean like for
me like
personally
i i find like the most badass people are
the people who like live till like the
late their late ages and they're like
they seem fit they seem able and then
one day they just decide to like their
body just decides all right peace out
yeah you know that's the way i would
want to go you know i don't want like
that i think everyone wants to go like
that yeah but like life is brutal it is
i like uh i think it's like the
tezukosama the the guy who basically
popularized manga he died while drawing
manga in the hospital then and i'm like
that's so [ __ ] badass the fact that
like this man literally till the moment
he died was doing what he wanted to do
yeah god's going to be doing that final
ten pull
just like that i just need one more
he gets 10 ssrs and he's like
connor's going to be on like jump king
20.
no but yeah because like my my like my
grandma right now is uh
is still alive and like she's in like
her late 90s right now and i remember
when i introduced her to sydney for the
first time
uh and i remember i was telling sydney
oh you know she's she's in the 90s you
know i think you've definitely told this
story have i told his story
i think you have maybe
i don't know have fun
unfortunately do a cliff notes okay so
yeah uh my grandma like squeezed took
sydney's hand and squeezed it she
squeezed it so hard that sydney was like
writhing in pain for like a good hour
because of how hard she squeezed it um
and yeah that was that was a cliff notes
for the story because i think maybe i
have taught this on trash too so
basically your grandma's a giga chat
yeah yeah have you ever heard this story
i think so yeah yeah i think
i can't i can't see sometimes you can't
tell if you told if i've told you this
at a bar or something
on a podcast unfortunately we talk
a lot unfortunately we do talk a lot i
wrote i saw a recent comment on one of
the trash today's episodes being like
it's so impressive how the boys still
managed to find topics that they've
never taught i don't even know i'm like
yeah i don't even know i just talk and
like sometimes we get called out for it
sometimes we don't i don't know
it's whatever yeah definitely spoke
about [ __ ] up fish in the ocean i know
that have we no we haven't oh
so many [ __ ] up little fish